you mentioned the reactions around the
world the tearing of the posters this
incident at the Sydney Opera house and
we we have a clip of we've pulled the
clip from that incident which as
horrible as it is I do want to play just
to have people absorb it and also
because it sparked a tweet thread of it
partially sparked a tweet thread of
yours that I want to discuss with you
okay so let's roll a little bit of that
clip
the theice
[Music]
I mean it is just shocking to see this
happening in a place like Australia and
I am curious if seeing these kind of
reactions in you know I don't know
English-speaking countries uh has
changed your political views at all you
you posted this thread on October 25th
saying that the the beginning of the
thread you write that the aftermath of
October 7th is a test for the west and
for all open societies societies that
nominally believe in freedom of speech
and the press such societies are now at
a Crossroads and must must think about
the direction they wish to head what do
you do about this kind of Jew hatred um
I'll just pose that question back to you
here what do you think an open and free
Society should do in the face of the
kind of hatred and vitri all we see on
display in that
clip so well I called that I eventually
wrote an essay on this I called it the
Dilemma of the West uh because I don't
think there's an easy answer to it all
my life I've been a very uh passion
advocate for freedom of speech freedom
of press and I said nominally respecting
freedom speech and press because
obviously over the last five years or so
eight years or so 10 years in America
and elsewhere freedom of speech has been
under attack and uh that's been deeply
disturbing to me uh both freedom of
speech both as a um as a cultural
norm uh and often sometimes as an actual
regulation there have been attempts to
ctail speech curtail opinions that made
people uncomfortable and certainly
culturally using norms and and
non-governmental methods to uh reduce
honesty on the part of people about what
they really think and feel and I think
that's you know very bad and uh a few
people still agree with me on that but
it's surprising how much in America and
in the west that is a controversial
opinion um at the same time uh do we
make any distinction this is what what I
was trying to ask in that Twitter thread
and in the essay do we want to make any
distinction between say unpop political
opinions and um Jew hatred racism uh
exhortations to
violence
um I would make a distinction
between writing and rallying uh the
thing I find disturbing about the
rallying and the thing I find disturbing
about the tearing down of the posters is
there's a implicit threat of violence
behind
them um in that clip you just showed you
know my um arabic's not what he used to
but I think those are uh Jihad flags
being waved where Jihad is about killing
infidels um and I you know what do you
do about that you just say well that's
their opinion we don't agree with it um
in the way that the
Sydney city of Sydney dealt with that
rally is they told Jews to stay away
from the Sydney Opera House and if you
look at that clip carefully
not carefully just look at it the second
time you'll see policemen in reflective
S standing on the the um the steps there
in the background watching this I I
don't know what else one could do uh
besides watch it I'm not suggesting that
that that they should storm the group
for saying what they said um and you
know and it really I don't think there's
an
easy way to deal with this um I used the
other example in that essay that
uh at some I think pro-israel rally
there was a group of of Jews who
conducted an evening prayer service it
was a very small group maybe 15 people
saying the evening prayer service but
nearby was either a pro Palestinian
Rally
or uh an an a response to the prois
rally a police barricade there and there
were dozens maybe hundreds of people
shouting free Palestine while these Jews
were trying to say their evening prayers
and you know what do we say about that
do we say that's just protest do we do
we make a distinction between a public
space and a private space so for example
if uh people want to hold a
um a rally on behalf of either Palestine
or Israel in a college campus meeting
room do people have the freedom should
they have the freedom to chant things in
response to that and you know it really
is a tragically beautiful example of how
difficult it is
to
legislate kindness a lot of what
underlies uh the American culture
of trust of discourse of searching for
the truth of mutual respect is
inherently cultural it's not legislated
you can't legislate it and when it
disappears attempts to legislate it are
not going to work so I don't think
there's a simple attractive magic answer
to how do you deal with speech that is
um
violent uh how do you deal with a March
that has violence around it and just to
leave I'll finish with talking about the
posters uh what's depressed me watching
it from a distance here in Israel is how
many people when they film the folks
tearing down the posters beg them to
stop and beg them to explain themselves
why are you doing this they cry out and
that's the tone it's it's it's a it's a
begging instead of saying uh I don't
approve of that and to stand in their
way and many of you watching this I'm
sure saw the clip of the New York
construction worker who got in the face
of someone tearing down the posters and
said this is America you don't do that
and I'm not gonna let you and
intimidated the guy very very uh uh
unattractively to to get him to stop but
what's the
alternative and the current alternative
which I don't particularly like is of
taking photos of of these of these
people and and identifying them and
trying to get them fired and you know I
I don't think somebody should be fired
for a moment of emotional response to a
kidnapped child that maybe makes them
uncomfortable for a thousand reasons and
but how do we handle that as a society
it's not an easy question yeah so one
thing I wanted to ask you about that is
there's the cultural component which you
alluded to there at the end with should
there be social consequen quences for
tearing down a a poster of someone who's
been abducted or yelling something
horrible like gas the Jews at a protest
I would say certainly the latter I would
not want to employ someone who was in
that video uh but then there's the
question the very just real you know
political question of should this be
allowed um and is it it is there
something in sufficient about just the
the straightforward liberal or
libertarian framework
of you have to allow the bad speech
particularly in a in a public space to
take place and you draw the line at
actual violence not really nasty words
you know we tolerate for instance
famously here the westbo Baptist Church
saying horrible things on public grounds
outside of funerals I mean you can't
imagine something much worse than that
and kind of the cultural response has
been like these gangs of motorcycle
these motorcycle gangs follow them
around and like drown them out with the
motorcycle so there's cultural response
but they're they're protected in their
speech is is there something that's not
sufficient in that that framework for
this particular problem in your opinion
well I want to I want to bring in
something I heard from Tom Palmer who
you may know uh from uh Atlas uh and who
is a longtime uh friend of
mine I don't remember when this was it
decades ago I got into an argument with
Tom about freedom of speech and I you
know I said I don't like that the Nazis
marched in skoki for example skoki is a
Jewish
neighborhood uh suburb of Chicago and
the Nazis March through the streets of
skoki and um someone recently pointed
out to me yeah there were about two
dozen of them if there had been a
100,000 maybe you'd feel differently
about that March but I said at the time
they have a right to March I I can never
we can never know what where truth is in
a democracy the whole beauty of freedom
of speech is to allow diverse viewpoints
to be expressed PE
peacefully uh and Tom didn't agree with
that Tom felt very strongly and I'm sure
he still does and I starting to think
he's right that freedom of speech should
not be allowed by people
for people who don't believe in freedom
of speech that is if you are part of the
Nazis or the Communists and I would put
it Hamas in with this also which is a a
grotesque Theocratic death cult um it
doesn't believe in freedom of speech
I'll just put a footnote here that story
came out yesterday that that there were
a bunch of photographers and journalists
who went with Hamas on October 7th
through the Gap in the fence and
chronicled and photograph the atrocities
and that this was an ethical violation
and I'm thinking do you really think
there are any journalists in Gaza do you
native journalists do you really think
there are people who live in Gaza who
can report who can tell the truth who
can say critical things about Kamas of
course there aren't of course everyone
there will at least say that they
support Kamas and will act accordingly
they do not hold by the journalistic
standards that we like to think uh other
journalists hold by and Eric times had a
slight Challenge on this they had a uh a
journalist there that they used as a
Stringer who admires Hitler and had
posted on on social media how great
Hitler was but the times assured us that
he really reported very objectively as
if you could possibly know so the these
kind of
insane um situations where you're
granting rights and freedoms to people
who would be thrilled to either slit
your throat or take those freedoms away
from you seems a
bit strange and so Tom's view was if the
goal of not any individual because
that's we don't can't measure it and
it's hard to to assess and who knows but
organizations that have as their
Charter the the the Revolutionary desire
to take away from freedoms from other
people should not be given those
freedoms and although it's hard for me
to say that to agree with Tom I I I
think he's probably right so any one
protester might let them say their say
from The River To The Sea even though
that means killing me and my friends
here uh and and ending the Jewish State
um I I would probably let them say that
or or put it in a say it in a classroom
but an organization that wants
that believes in that or that believes
in in in gassing jewes or murdering Jews
or any other group should probably not
be
given the same rights to express
themselves as other groups uh maybe they
shouldn't be given a permit to walk on
the streets of skoki I'm in I'm in
Florida and the governor here has just
uh attempted to ban student groups that
are supportive of Palestine on the
pretense that they say that they're in
alignment with what happened in Gaza and
therefore he's saying they're providing
material support to them um I honestly F
you know even though I find that
repugnant I find it I also find it
disturbing as a gubernatorial action to
and like a very clear example of how
once you start saying well they are
somehow affiliated with a group that is
murderous that they themselves don't
have a right to express all these other
views on a campus so that is the the
heart of my concern with what you're
saying even though I I acknowledge the
very problem I agree with you I I do not
think let me let me be clear about a
couple things um Israel makes lots of
mistakes does some horrific things I'm
not proud of them I'm ashamed of them
don't want them to continue um uh we
could debate what those might be I do
not think um the current ground
defensive in Gaza is anything to be
ashamed of I think it's morally
appropriate and although tragically I'm
sure many thousands perhaps of civilians
have died in Gaza which is horrible and
I'm and a tragedy Israel gave them weeks
to to leave and Hamas at the point of a
gun wouldn't let many of them leave so I
hold Hamas responsible for that having
said that Israel's done plenty of
horrific things to Palestinians in Gaza
Palestinians in the West Bank and it's
perfectly legitimate to be opposed to
Israeli policies it's perfectly
legitimate to support a Palestinian
State it's perfectly legitimate to fight
for the rights of Palestinians say to
water rights or to fight for their
ability to to get better police
protection or you fill in the blank
there plenty of things that you can be
Pro Palestine about without being
anti-jew uh but if you're anti-jew it
seems to be crossing the line so groups
that are pro Palestinian should be
allowed on college campuses and
elsewhere in my view uh as long as it
doesn't shade into the celebration of
murdering people which seems like
crossing a line now they would disagree
by the way and to be fair to them you
know at these Pro Palestine rallies in
say London where 100,000 people marched
many them chanting from the river to the
sea or free Palestine which does not
mean um rights for Palestinians it means
the land that Israel's on now should
belong to um the Palestinians and not to
to the Jewish
State uh they also say things like by
any means necessary and of course
they're an underdog and they don't have
a good military and of course they're
blockaded from getting military weapons
not perfectly successfully but so
perhaps you can make the case that they
have to use means that others would not
stomach I guess for me it's mainly the
enjoying of it that's so disturbing hey
thanks for watching that clip from our
conversation with Russ Roberts about
life in Israel in the aftermath of the
October 7th terrorist attacks you can
watch another clip from that
conversation over here or the full
conversation right over here